[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we want
what are we talking about with with kids
crawling around we're talking about
talk about new generation of sports and
i feel like like even my dad they all
played sports and they played all was he
like serious my dad was like the typical
kind of american uh first generation
american but he was in in cleveland ohio
played baseball football basketball but
they just kind of played where like then
my generation started playing like aau
and like all these serious competitive
stuff and you kind of chose a sport in
like fourth or fifth grade take it up a
notch and you got like lebron james and
these freaks right and then we were
talking about jiu jitsu how like taika
is doing it at such a young age which i
think is great because it is so much
like body control and obviously like
discipline and like interacting with
humans without being like angry like how
can you do this without like getting out
your anger just punch a kid in the face
but then when he's 18 if he sticks with
it or his peers like how badass they're
gonna be compared to what's going on
what i was talking to nick was i've
already started meeting these kids
because they'll be like a kid that's
like 16 and i just see them moving on
the mat like hella crazy yeah and i'm
like damn that's nuts like this guy has
like almost black belt level movement
but he's 16 and i'm like how long have
you been doing it for because i've been
doing it for 10 years now yeah or you
get freaky athletes like that's what you
see in the ufc like i'm a pretty casual
fan but i know a lot of guys have
watched for 15-ish years you used to
just see guys that were like technically
you know like a seven out of ten but
athletically there may be a five out of
ten they maybe play d just tough they
played d3 football yeah you know but now
you have like bones jones well what do
his brothers do well they're both freaks
in the nfl he's got a championship ring
he's dude tj1 jj what dude yeah [ __ ]
crazy yeah you got freak genetics now
yeah right so now they're starting
they're going to start entering and you
got the 10 out of 10 genetics now you're
like and it's going to raise the sport
even higher just because of that yeah
that's even better yeah no no no for
sure no it's all super troopers no for
sure you want to see the best do it dude
look at nfl kickers dude the idea of
hitting a 60 yarder used to be nuts and
now like doing 55s and [ __ ] have you
seen some of those guys they're [ __ ]
jacked yeah yeah like nfl kickers like
one works out with jordan our buddy uh
this uh trainer of ours and he's [ __ ]
jacked this kicker i think it might be
indianapolis actually i don't know where
no that's not rodrigo blankenship dude
he's a little dude uh it might be a
titan's kicker i forgot but this dude's
just [ __ ] yoked he's like
bench pressing 405 and stuff have you
heard his kick concept in sports it was
it's like a collective consciousness
thing where it's like people didn't
believe certain things were possible
until people start breaking those
barriers
yeah there's a huge one in powerlifting
once people break that barrier then you
see like people knocking it out the park
what's the equivalent of powerlifting
power lifting like west side which is
like a famous power lifting gym kind of
had something like that where like no
one could pull like 800 and then one
dude crushes 800 and within the first
six months like five other guys pull 800
yeah it's weird
that was a smaller community like people
had pulled 800 in the world but that was
just like your personal training
partners did then you crush it
that's weird how it happened is it four
minute mile five minute mile i think
it's four actually two that's stupid
like a 550 19 like they say impossible
those guys are moving dude a four minute
mile [ __ ] me you're sprinting for four
no no you're fast yeah yeah yeah fast as
[ __ ] dude i was in college basketball
shape i ran a 550. yeah that's pretty
[ __ ] good no i cried and i was yeah
your legs that was done you see the guy
who uh
you see the guy who raced like usain
bolt and then he like when the race was
over he beat him or whatever and he
turned around and he like started going
like this to the guy because like it's
like the same kind of thing yeah
like you said this you
just because he beat him he's like dude
you're the [ __ ] man yeah yeah that's
crazy that's kind of like i think uh you
know and um like an entertainment that's
why there's like so many people that
want to fight for roles too is they feel
like because of that mental barrier if
they don't see people on the screen that
look like them they don't feel like
yeah it's even possible yeah yeah that's
true that's the danger with telling
people something's impossible for so
[ __ ] long like you don't even bother
trying after a while that's like my mom
telling me that i always have to wear a
jacket because i don't have strong
immunity like uh americans do yeah
that's my we have the same moment you
guys got immunity issues no like [ __ ]
i don't know asian mom logics they just
say that [ __ ] they always say white kids
and black kids are like they're meant to
be outside like they don't have sweaters
oh you guys are a little yeah yeah
you're a little [ __ ]
yeah maybe your mom's right
[ __ ] when you go to a summer camp i
should bring a sweater
that's just what mom's doing no yeah my
dad made me wear it mom say wear a
sweater bring a jacket but do they
compare to other races
after that phrase not always a racial
connection for my asian moms it's a
racial connection
what's racial about the tables oh cause
we're white dudes over here that's
[ __ ] up
mom wasn't born here
where's your mom argentina but you're
spicy white yeah is that spicy
you've got something going on you speak
spanish no very mediocre i know it's bad
my mom's a spanish teacher lived her
whole life in argentina
yeah but she didn't want to bring her
work home with her so my grandma lived
with us too and grandma spoke spanish
but then my dad's uh italian from
cleveland and so he was like well my kid
my kids are speaking spanish like my
first words were all spanish my dad's
like i can't understand my own
hilarious that's kids what happens
i think i don't know does he speak like
we'll say i have an accent what but i
think that's insanity i don't know well
you say cats and [ __ ] yeah i do say some
weird [ __ ] weird [ __ ] like that yeah no
people say i say weird [ __ ] i have an
accent but i think it's because my dad
i'm always like is he talking about
kitty cats i don't get this now but he's
like a black man from harlem in 1915
hey what's up cool cat thanks for having
me on the show man yeah he's
the guy in dirty harry he's like hey man
i gots to know
i got to know
because he's like do you know how many
bullets did i fire or whatever oh this
is the best that's a good time
so you're not you're nothing no you're
just italian american argentinian
argentinian i guess is your does your
dad speak like an italian guy from the
east coast so a little bit like
cleveland cleveland kind of has like the
like a wisconsin boston like a diluted
wisconsin boston like in between because
it's in between so they'll say something
the shoulder is what you said they don't
like
it
is that why they named you mike yeah
mikey hey mikey oh they call you mikey
no uh made my parents what's a regional
term you grew up with yeah
yeah they say pop so we say papa let me
get a pop but i'll call my dad pop too
but no yeah in terms of soda soda pop
that's different yeah some places call
it uh cola do you still call it pop
soda pop no i chose a lot what about
like italian based not too much did your
parents what kind of food did they make
growing up so argentina you make like
super normal stuff like my my family's
all ranchers they still all live down
there steak and potatoes steak potatoes
bread but like like probably the best
steak on the planet but not hamburger
helper like the italians were where i
grew up no no we're not cake it's got is
it the gaucho steak or whatever you call
it yeah yeah gauchos yeah all my cousins
are gauchos that's cool is chimichurri
or like empanadas
uh
what kind of normal stuff how connected
are you to your argentinian roots do you
go i got gaucho knives
they had a couple of gouchers i mean
chill with your family in their farm
once um
but my mom before coven goes every year
multiple times were you in buenos aires
hey the cultured guy oh no he's the host
have you seen evita no
no it's like your family your culture
that i know i don't know it doesn't
mulan you know you got it it's very
doper though that's all we got i like
that that's your move
i don't think we have anything you know
you know there's a lot of nazi refugees
in argentina
right all of them a lot of my cousins
kind of look like me they look more
white than me they're like blonde they
look like you bro actually when you said
messi earlier your side profile looks
like messy yeah but he's italian he's
like italian argentinian italian like
argentina is kind of like america like
everyone just moved down there i see
it's all european that's what i realized
about mexico they just speak spanish
yeah because i was like hold on man this
is just like america just that their
indigenous people are not registered or
like they don't have their own area yeah
they're just everyone's you're a little
browner because you're outside and
you're more close to the equator and a
little more mixed but there's true hell
of white people yeah that are just
mexican that i didn't i was like
what the [ __ ] i'm stupid i've been in
l.a all my life yeah argentina is kind
of like that like we'll have some more
indigenous looking folks they're a
little darker but did you know that down
by the equator you're moving faster than
everywhere else on the whole [ __ ]
earth
the earth is flat dude
what the [ __ ] are you talking about wait
if the earth is flat is it rotating like
this or is it rotating like this who the
[ __ ] said it's rotating it's rotating
like that like this no it's like it's
like a microwave yeah
yeah who even said it's rotate it's like
a hamster wheel
what do you mean the moon rotates around
us i think flat earthers think the
moon's fake no no no it goes like this
the moon and the sun goes like this
the moon is a light source that seems
legit though yeah i think i i think i
like that theory better but also
like don't don't flat earthers believe
there's an ice wall yep i think there's
i think multiple beliefs some people
believe like the globe theory
i think that's like where like like
where the truman show we talk about like
there's a flat earth but then it's just
like a dog like a half dog
you're talking about the firmament i
don't know that's the yeah that's the
above that's the above glass yeah and so
then like nothing's moving oh [ __ ] maybe
we're just an ant farm to like some
higher could be today's video is brought
to you by babel i'm kind of mad but i'm
kind of happy why fifty percent mad
because they didn't have this in my
childhood but 50 happy because they have
something like this today it is the
number one selling language learning app
and i wish that i could learn languages
on the go like this earlier in life so
then you know by now i probably know
more languages yeah because they make it
so easy where all the lessons are 15
minutes so it's not like taking a
foreign language class for a whole hour
and they're cramming all that
information and it's hard to memorize
it's short pieces of information that
you can learn
and also they use language experts
instead of ais you're learning the most
practical way of saying it
pronunciation and the right accent you
speak into it and then they correct you
yeah yeah it's not like bobby hill's mom
trying to teach you spanish yeah espana
espanol
it's pretty awesome too because they
have like 14 different languages that
you can choose from like turkish
have you ever heard of that that's what
the turkeys speak yup or
english have you ever heard of that
no
or
what else do they got german
guten tag
indonesians
yoshi sudarso french's yup they got a
lot of different options 14. yeah that's
a lot so start your language learning
today by going to babble.com that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com and use the code off the
record to get a free three months when
you purchase your first three months so
that's six months for the price of three
go to babel.com all you have to do is
use the promo code off the record to get
six months for the price of three i know
you guys trying to be polygons so start
your journey now yeah you dummies did
you watch that flat earth thing on the
netflix documentaries it was a so at the
end they the flat earthers they rented
this super expensive equipment to test
because they wanted a laser beam from
one point to another and then they said
that if we calculate it
yeah it won't it won't
it will bet or whatever right
basically they disprove themselves and
they kept taking the test
but they didn't want to believe that
yeah it's not that long right before you
can start to see the the curve yeah it's
like only a couple miles or something
well that's why snipers have to account
for yeah yeah and drop and yeah yeah
yeah
damn
stupid what's dropping like bullet drop
oh [ __ ] oh this building i only know
that from video games i love it yeah
modern warfare dude i was like you got
to account for the curvature of the
[ __ ] earth
[Laughter]
i was listening to bill bird talking
about the flat earth theory and he goes
before like the internet came nobody
talked about sure would be embarrassed
because nobody nobody ever mentioned it
but yeah
well just be now because you have the
internet you know you have a bunch of
idiots all over the world just agreeing
with each other like yeah you're right
this is [ __ ] and now we have a whole
community of people and conventions
where people think the earth is flat and
it is like to what end like why what do
you gain from convincing me near this
flat
like what changes wow you actually
sounded like bill burr for a second i'm
not kidding that was actually pretty
weird
yeah bitcoin convention coming up i'm
sure would you ever be down and go i'm
down with the bitcoin convention what
happens at a bitcoin convention i don't
know but uh someone just told me that
there's a bitcoin convention coming up
in vegas yeah you live in the convention
capital i think orlando for some reason
in vegas for the convention capitals i
want to go and dunk on all the coiners
because i [ __ ] beat them in the
ratios so yeah hey
luna my tara has been printing bitcoin
[ __ ] i love it
dude this guy's high level bro
i love the highlights if i pay you to
consult the front oh no no i don't like
that bread i'll hook you up let's make
that bread yeah hit me up what do we
need a couple gpus and we just start a
farm in here we could do that too if you
want but it'll get hot in here dude i
wouldn't i don't know
dude like computer graphics cards oh man
dude i know that one's a normal that one
yeah that is some normal [ __ ] we gotta
cool it though he doesn't even know what
a normie is i know dude because he's an
army you're dying at norms everyone yeah
i am getting a miner for this office
though really i already talked to the
voicemail oh i'm down dude yeah i'll buy
some gp i'll go steal a gpu i edit that
out
i'll go steal some [ __ ] we got some
rakes my rig at home rips i have a i
have a rig we got a couple rigs that rip
dude what are you guys mining nothing we
gained they're just gonna be a big guy
but they ripped but they ripped oh i get
it yeah like that they're [ __ ] baby
yeah what do you mean it rips
like what if i said my porsche ripped
what kind of frame rate on that porsche
oh my frame rate on my portion
escape from tarkov we get [ __ ] 200
frames
that's that's per second right place it
because it burns out do my computer my
computer actually doesn't rip as hard as
my roommates it's a pretty decent
computer i i'm a fake nerd like i cool
it like a [ __ ] do you have all
those [ __ ] tubes and [ __ ] there's
fans all through it i i know very little
did you build it no i'm a fake
nowadays though you can't really build
it any cheaper than you get pre-built so
like building's kind of fake news
nowadays if you buy like a sick ass
computer how much does it cost mine was
1800 like three years ago and you play
any game as fast as [ __ ] i mean i stream
so it can do it yeah where do you stream
uh i used to stream a lot of like just
shooters call of duty stuff we're pretty
decent or escape from target you're
playing sea of thieves oh dude we [ __ ]
around with cfds a little bit this guy
dude you want to stream i was trying to
get david i'm in dude i was talking to
david i was like david i know you don't
really game but we could get david on
see if these we could just make like a
[ __ ] yeah group and we'll just shmob
let's go let's fly let's sail the seven
seasons we could get bart on a game like
that i know we could explore the whole
flat earth dude
dude
you're just we'll go to the [ __ ] edge
of the earth and prove it yeah make an
ice wall yo that's an objective it's
like a cartoon ass pirates of the
caribbean and we're all on a ship
together we just run around oh yeah i
showed them last week i showed or two
weeks ago i showed them the video how
many people can you have in your crew oh
[ __ ] a million so is it like world of
warcraft kind of but just pirates dude
but it's only on pc uh no i think it's
on xbox it's microsoft game dude there's
so many games like that where mostly
what it is is you're chilling together
talking that's why kids don't go out
no for sure it's cause they stay home
and [ __ ] have chill parties it's
incredible imagine going out right when
by the time you get there you're like
okay i'm i can't wait to leave whereas
with sea of thieves and [ __ ] like that
you're like i'm gonna [ __ ] be
chilling and you got food yep you eat
drinks if you want you live in vegas in
la norcal we can still kick it every
night and just [ __ ] around yeah do a
pirate chat on gta yes no same idea yeah
you just pull missions over and over and
over but cfu's is even less complicated
that's true oh yeah yeah but the same
idea though you want to get some sick
ass loot so you can buy some sick ass
customizable items that you can wipe it
on your friends faces with yeah i'm
trying to pour buckets bro yeah dude
you're fixing the ship steve steve put
us on game last time told us that we we
could drill holes in people's [ __ ] yeah
that's what we want to do that's right
it's cool and you want to fill people's
ships up with buckets of water yeah i
told them forever no yeah and emptying
your own boat takes forever it takes
forever very frustrating
you don't want to think of [ __ ]
you're not made though dude it is
pretty well everything's so fun you can
do anything nowadays
i'm down to like mob and antagonize
people on the internet what are going to
do bart you like tarkov too this game
tarkov we play it's developed by
russians and it's so interesting loves
russians i know well it's all about guns
that's all and this guy loves guns and
russians i think it's illegal don't
quote me but they you use like uh name
brand oh [ __ ]
and you have to
find and put every piece of gun together
exact ammo exact mags and then you're
out there and then you die in one bullet
like it's as realistic as possible
you're just out there is it like hunger
games it's kind of like hunger games
it's it's a post-apocalyptic world and
you you can go with your homies but you
can kill your homies
it's not like call of duty where it'll
say like steve like it won't say your
name i don't know if it's you sometimes
so we gotta be screaming i say hey man
show me a two and you give me one of
these
yeah you have no clue bro you have no
clue you end up capping each other
there's no text or labels on who's
nothing there's no map that's like some
real [ __ ] you just drop down there's no
no there's no holy [ __ ] i'd be so bad at
this game for hours trying to figure out
the map wow no there's no map this
sounds like that daisy [ __ ] yeah so it's
it's modern day daisy it's like an
upgraded version of daisy because that
game suck complete [ __ ] no this
game's sick dude but you you're like an
eo tag you got to get your little
[ __ ] scope on there like all name bro
that sounds funny you gotta put it all
together different calipers and uh uh
different like um flesh rounds versus
armor rounds so you gotta like all right
these guys probably have some money so
they might have good armor i gotta use
these rounds what's the incentive to not
die in this game to keep your [ __ ]
because as soon as you die your sick
gun's gone as soon as you have a if you
have a dope m40 you just spent an hour
making
then you die you're never gonna see it
again so it's like that whack ass daisy
[ __ ] yeah it's very similar usually like
on average to stay alive
well if you're good like my my homie
kyle shout out kyle do kyle is good so i
just run with him and he kills everybody
so you just think that's good
do you build a basin [ __ ] no
no eating no no yeah there's there's no
hunting but there's food and water if
you dehydrate your screen structure goes
like woof
sounds fun man
[Laughter]
it's not quite sea of thieves it's not
quite see it no what is bro different
experiences first of all and see at
these i can get so [ __ ] up that i'll
start puking on you so it's kind of like
that and then it blocks your screen yeah
see what these are dude and then if i'm
holding a bucket and you puke it'll land
on my bucket and then i can throw it
back on it really yeah
it's the best [ __ ] game ever
these games
it's first-person view i was playing c
at these with isaac and we got so [ __ ]
up we were throwing up on each other i
had the kid laughing so hard he couldn't
breathe
i want to play with steve bro i want to
play with him
[Music]
[Music]
you